i want to show you another way to solve
this particular proof
it's an inequality result that we could
do with just sort of strict algebra that
was the first approach that we took
uh but i want to show you there's
another sort of perspective you can take
on this which
is not more efficient or more elegant
than the previous
solution method however as an additional
perspective on this problem i think it's
always valuable to take another
different angle
that's the first thing to note and
secondly um for another
problem this approach might actually be
more efficient
um more succinct depending on the kind
of problem that you encounter so
it's always good to have you know more
tools in your toolbox even if it's not
the best tool for this particular task
it might be for another one so let's
just remember what this is asking us
we get given this pair of numbers a and
b we're told that they up to six and
that they're both
positive and then this is the inequality
result that we have to prove
now like i said before you can just sort
of go at this with sort of an
algebraic hacksaw and find some squares
in there that are going to be positive
you know take everything over to the
left hand side
try and prove that that whole expression
is going to be greater than or equal to
zero
and that worked fine however
i want you to notice that when you think
about this object over here one over a
plus one over b
we can actually use it uh as kind of a
launch pad for actually thinking about
this
visually graphically we can think about
what does this look like
as a picture can i can i get a sense of
what this should look like
on like a two-dimensional set of axes
and then can i show that when i add
these two things together
it's always going to be greater than or
equal to two-thirds that's another
approach that we could take
now admittedly when you have a look at
this you're like oh my gosh i don't even
know where to start even if i think i
want to visualize this
it might not be obvious to you how you
would go about doing that so
let me kind of nudge you along the way
for starters i'll admit it doesn't look
much like something to graph
when you look at this because there's an
a and a b rather than say
x's and y's right that's what we're used
to graphing y equals something or other
in terms of x i want you to remember
that these are just labels
right just because we usually call it an
x axis there's no reason why it has to
be
we could just as easily have an a axis
or a time axis or a population
axis so these labels um can be
arbitrarily changed
and so we shouldn't just sort of expect
like oh this is just locked into
thinking about this algebraically
but i do need to do a little bit of work
to make it more obvious how i can
visualize this
so i noticed that in the question i get
this relationship between a and b
and what that will allow me to do is to
turn this which is
a two variable expression it's got an a
in it and a b
i can use this a plus b equals six to do
some rearrangement and substitution
to eliminate one of these variables so i
don't just have
i don't have a and b i'll have just a or
just b
so one way i could do that is say for
example if i take this over here
and say a plus b equals six so therefore
it stands to reason
that b will be equal to six take away
a therefore i can substitute that in to
this
expression here i can have a one over a
plus one over
six minus a and if i had that as you
know x's instead if i had
1 over x plus 1 over
6 minus x this looks a whole lot more
familiar like oh
i think i know what this looks like i
can graph it now before we go off
and do that and there are a couple of
other things i want to take note of i'm
not actually going to do this in terms
of x's because
um there's no specific reason we have to
as i pointed out the labels the
pronumerals are arbitrary
so i'm actually going to leave it in
terms of a's so
i'll just put those x's away and
replace them with a so this is what i'm
going to deal with and then secondly i
want you to note
we have this restriction here we noted
that a and b had to be positive
now that means that when i have a look
at this i already have the fact that a
is greater than zero
a is greater than zero that's known but
i also can say
not only does a have to be bigger than
something there's actually also an upper
bound
on a a has to be lower than a certain
value and i wonder if you can spot
what the upper bound is before i tell
you um there's at least two ways to be
able to see
that a can't be any bigger than a
certain amount and that's going to be
important for us when we're graphing
because then i don't need to graph the
whole thing
i just need to graph number one the path
that's greater than zero and then number
two the path that's less than
some other value so the first thing you
can say is well let's have a look at
this right
a and b they add together to give you
six right
both a and b have to be positive so you
can see here
a can't be arbitrarily large right if a
was say something like 10
then 10 plus b equals 6 b would have to
be
negative in this case negative 4 and
that violates what i know about b b
has to be positive so a can't be ten
it can't be nine a can't be eight or
seven
a can't even be six because then if i
had six plus b
equals six b would have to be exactly
zero and i know i
can't be zero b has to be like i said
strictly positive
so therefore i can say well just looking
at that and the fact that b has to be
positive
a has to be less than six i can reason
that through
and you can see i've got not just a
lower bound but an upper bound
if that's a bit too uh hand wavy and
intuitive for you there's an algebraic
way to show that as well which maybe you
would find
easier to accept if you go back to let's
say i'm going all
color crazy today if you go back to this
restriction that
b is going to be greater than zero we
can go back to uh
this result here that i used to
eliminate b and say it's 6 minus
a from that i can say well that means 6
minus a also
has to be greater than 0 6 minus a is
after all
equal to b so therefore it only takes a
little bit of rearrangement i mean if i
i'll leave a on the left hand side
because it's going to be the subject but
i'll subtract 6 from both sides and then
i'll multiply through
by negative one remembering that
multiplying both sides of an inequality
by a negative changes
the direction of the inequality and
there you go a is less than six there's
my upper bound so
what i could say in place of this is
that actually i'm considering
a between naught
and six so now think about what this is
going to look like
could we graph this shape from in the
domain
naught to six could we graph this shape
in the domain naught to six and the
answer is
absolutely we can so let's have a go at
doing this
reasonably neatly and see what we get
here right
so if i were to draw a graph here and
that's a terrible straight line let's
try that again
i'm happy with that if we think about
this first object here let's think about
the one over a
and do this in purple one over a is the
hyperbola
right and i'm only considering just the
one part of it so rather than like the
whole thing like so
um i only need the part from naught to
six so here i am from naught i'll never
get to the asymptote anyway and then i
go along
some distance to get to six so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to draw that
like so and
that can go off into you know towards
that asymptote as far as
we like and then i'm going to have an
open circle over there on the end
for 6. so there is 1
over a within this domain so maybe i'll
label that
1 over a now what does 1 over
6 minus a look like in the same domain
how can we understand the picture of
that well think about this in two ways
number one
you can see there's going to be a
horizontal
reflection that's happening here right
so you're gonna get a shape that is
um not not going up and then decreasing
it's gonna be
from the bottom and then increasing
right so it's been flipped around
and then secondly it's been shifted 6
units so in fact you're essentially
going to get this
shape but you're going to get it
backwards right so therefore
i can say i'm going to get a hollow
circle over here and then i'm going to
be increasing and i'll approach
just like i had an asymptote at 0 here
for 1 over a
i'm going to have an asymptote at 6
i guess it's going to line up with this
hollow circle
like so i really should put both should
know so we're going to get
an asymptote over here and don't forget
this is not an x
axis this is an a axis and if i call
this whole thing
y and this is my y
axis and here is y equals 1 over
6 minus a so you can see you know you
obviously can't substitute 6 into there
so that's why you're approaching this
asymptote
okay now remember i was pointing out
that there's a symmetry to this right
because it's been flipped over and it's
been moved
uh you know six units horizontally right
that means you might be able to even off
my diagram which is not that great a
diagram but i think it's good enough
you might be able to tell what this
critical point right here is right
because there is symmetry it's going to
be exactly halfway
between 0 and
6. so you can see by the symmetry here
and it's not difficult you could solve
these two simultaneously if you really
wanted
but this point here is going to be 3
and you can therefore say oh if the a
coordinate
is 3 then when you substitute a into
either of these curves here and here
you're going to get y equals 1 over 3 a
third
right so maybe i will draw that across
like so
so there's that vertical value
and now what i'm doing is i'm adding
these two things together right
so i'm adding at that point there i'm
adding one graph which is equal to a
third
and another graph which is equal to a
third a third
plus a third last i checked is equal to
two-thirds right now two-thirds should
grab your attention because you're like
hold on a second
that's what this question here was
saying when i add these two things
together i should be greater than or
equal to
two thirds so what that tells me this
spot here let's just draw this across
as well sorry my uh scale's not the
greatest but
it's enough for illustration that
apparently is the lowest that i'm going
to get
right so how do i actually prove that
that
is the case i'm guessing i'm
anticipating if
indeed this is true that the lowest this
can possibly go
is going to be two-thirds i'm guessing
i'm going to get some sort of shape
roughly like
this right which as you can see
two-thirds is where it bottoms out and
so you're greater than or equal to that
value
okay